This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有自动扶梯时还选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的心理坚韧、体能以及建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一番艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO点零。可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。欢迎收听《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年说起，那对我的意义重大。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及我们最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我觉得对于黑人来说，再也没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人身披铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改过这项特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们在20多岁时经历的重大生活改变与转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. One of the things that we tend to worry about more than anything else in our lives and especially in our 20s is love. Love is by far the theme that I get the most questions and worries about. And a big one is whether we even have the capacity to love and be loved, whether we are even worthy of that experience and why does that we feel like? Why not? And that is exactly what I want to discuss today and really delve into. Why is it that we feel so unlovable? Why is it that we are followed or overwhelmed by these doubts that we will never find anybody,
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，当然，我们要在这里剖析20多岁的心理。我们在生活中、尤其是在20多岁时最担心的事之一，毫无疑问就是爱。在所有让我收到最多提问和担忧的主题中，爱绝对高居榜首。其中一个很大的困惑是，我们是否具备去爱和被爱的能力，我们是否真的配得上这种经历，为什么我们会有这种感觉？为什么不呢？这正是我想在今天讨论并深入探讨的问题。为什么我们会觉得自己如此不可爱？为什么我们总是被这些怀疑所困扰或淹没，觉得自己永远找不到任何人，
that we will always be alone? And that we, you know, even if we do find somebody, we will have to settle with good enough rather than a love that is spectacular and amazing. It is a real mental prison to want something so bad and have this equally strong voice in your head telling you that you'll never have it or that you don't deserve it. Not only is this, you know, a really hard battle, especially when the voice is kind of coming from inside the house, but it's also so much more common than we think. That is one thing that I can promise you. There are so many of us, especially in this decade, walking around, feeling like love is not something that we deserve or something that we can have.
觉得自己永远都是孤身一人？而且你知道，即使我们真的找到了某人，我们也只能将就着找个“还过得去”的人，而不是去追求一份壮丽而惊艳的爱情。当内心极度渴望某样东西，脑海中却又有一个同样强烈的声音告诉你你永远得不到它、或者你不配拥有它时，这真是一种精神上的监狱。这不仅是一场异常艰难的战斗，尤其是当这种声音似乎来自内心深处时，而且它也比我们想象的要普遍得多。这是我可以向你们保证的一点。我们当中有很多人，特别是在这个十年里，四处游荡，觉得爱不是我们配拥有的东西，或者不是我们能拥有的东西。
and this experience, this mental state has some really striking psychological origins from childhood to even early romantic experiences or lack thereof in high school and our teen years, pivotal moments of rejection and shame that really cause us to internalize a lot of comparison and criticism and insecurity. So understanding where it all began, I think, is the first point for kind of accepting what we've been through, escaping the maze, and then truly feeling like we deserve vibrant love in our lives. And I mean truly deserve it.
这种经历、这种精神状态有着非常显著的心理根源，从童年到早期的浪漫经历，甚至是高中和青少年时期浪漫经历的空白，那些关键的拒绝和羞耻时刻，真的让我们内化了大量的比较、批评和不安全感。所以，弄清楚这一切是从哪里开始的，我认为这是接受我们所经历的一切、逃出迷宫、然后真正觉得自己生命中配得上充满活力的爱的第一步。我是说真正配得上。
These origin points of all of our self-doubts and self-believes about why we are unlovable, they might seem permanent. It might seem like our kind of destiny, but you can really rediscover or perhaps discover for the first time all of the things that make you brilliant and all the things that make you brilliant and all the things that make you quite honestly a catch and that there are so many people who would be so lucky to have you in their lives. And with that, you really raise your confidence, you raise your levels of self-love, and of course, you also raise the bar for what you deserve, the standard
所有关于我们为什么不可爱的自我怀疑和自我信念的起源，它们看起来可能是永久的。它可能看起来像是我们的某种命运，但你确实可以重新发现，或者也许是生平第一次发现，所有那些让你闪闪发光的东西，所有那些让你耀眼夺目的东西，以及所有那些老实说让你成为一个极具吸引力的人的特质，而且会有那么多人觉得拥有你将是无比幸运。有了这些，你真的能提升你的自信，提升你对自己的爱，当然，你也会提高你对所应得之物的标准，
for who gets to love you, rather than living in a scarcity state where anyone who comes along and promises you the bare minimum gets let in. So that's what we're going to discuss today. why do we feel so undeserving of love? Where does that come from? And what exactly can we do about it? How do we heal from the wounds that have created this belief system? So without further ado, let's get into it. To be vulnerable for a second, there was a point in my life where I was so desperate for love
设定谁才有资格去爱你的标准，而不是生活在一种匮乏的状态中——任何随便出现并承诺给你最低限度的人都能被允许进入你的生活。这就是我们今天要讨论的内容。为什么我们觉得自己如此不配得到爱？这种感觉是从哪里来的？我们究竟该如何应对？我们如何治愈创造了这个信念系统的创伤？所以，废话不多说，让我们切入正题。坦白地说，我生命中曾有过这样一个阶段，我对爱的渴望如此强烈，
and at the same time felt so undeserving of it that anyone who even gave me like the slightest bit of attention. It felt like they were the one. It felt like I had met my soulmate. And it caused me to end up with a lot of people that at the end of the day, I never even liked and who were most certainly not worth my time. And I can recognize that now. I can recognize that all of my habits stemmed from how unworthy of love that I felt. And these same habits were not only attracting these people to me, but they were also making it so I kept them in my orbit, even when time and time again, they proved to me they did not deserve to be there. Essentially, this, like, deeply rooted sense that I was unlovable meant that I had no boundaries
与此同时又觉得自己如此不配得到它，以至于任何哪怕只给我一点点关注的人。我都觉得他们就是那个人。我觉得我遇到了灵魂伴侣。这导致我最终和很多人在一起，到头来，我甚至从来没真正喜欢过他们，而且他们绝对不值得我浪费时间。我现在能认清这一点了。我能认清我所有的习惯都源于我对自己感到多么不配得到爱。而正是这些同样的习惯，不仅吸引了这样的人来到我身边，而且还让我把他们留在了我的生活圈里，即使他们一次又一次向我证明他们根本不配待在那里。本质上，这种扎根极深的“我不可爱”的感觉意味着我没有任何界限，
because the boundaries that I should have set were just going to be another reason that people wouldn't be able to love me. But if I lowered them, more people could be let in. If I pleased everybody, I could be loved. And I didn't, you know, quite think about why exactly those people wouldn't have been around before my boundaries were lowered. But again, that is the nature of this really insidious self-believe system that you are unlovable. Not only is it that we accept less for ourselves, we also sabotage when we have a really good thing going on. Because when you feel unworthy of that kind of affection and kindness being shouted on you, you react from a place fear. This experience is so unfamiliar and it feels like it doesn't belong to you. So you find,
因为我本该设置的界限，只会成为别人无法爱我的又一个借口。但如果我降低界限，就会有更多的人被放进来。如果我取悦所有人，我就能被爱。而且我并没有（你知道的）仔细去想，为什么在我的界限降低之前，那些人根本不会留在我身边。但话说回来，这就是那种真正阴险的“你不可爱”的自我信念系统的本质。我们不仅为自己接受了更少的东西，当我们的生活真正顺风顺水时，我们也会进行自我破坏。因为当你觉得自己不配得到倾注在你身上的那种affection（爱意）和善良时，你的反应是出于恐惧。这种经历是如此陌生，感觉它根本不属于你。所以你会寻找，
you know, some kind of way unconsciously to end it before the other person wakes up and realizes that for themselves. It's again, a whole labyrinth, feeling unworthy of love causes us to miss out on a lot of opportunities because we close ourselves off. We reject ourselves before we even get to the start line. And it can also be lonely. In fact, I think that is one of the core pillars of this experience is that it creates loneliness. It makes us inherently somebody that is isolated and perhaps living very solitary, even when we are surrounded by other people. And it continues to shape a series of behaviours that sadly keep it that way.
你知道的，某种无意识的方式去结束它，免得对方醒悟过来并为自己意识到这一点。这又是一个巨大的迷宫，觉得自己不配得到爱，让我们错失了很多机会，因为我们封闭了自己。我们在起跑线前就自我否定了。而且这也会让人感到孤独。事实上，我认为这是这种体验的核心支柱之一，那就是它会产生孤独感。它让我们本能地成为一个孤立的人，也许过着非常孤独的生活，即使我们被其他人包围。它继续塑造了一系列可悲地让这种情况持续下去的行为。
So let's talk about why that is. When we feel unlovable, it's not just that we feel generally undeserving of love, it often also means that we think there is something about us that makes us a fundamentally bad person or there is something about us that others would look at and immediately turn away from. You know, this could be some part of our personality that somebody has, you know, told us isn't attractive or isn't desirable. You know, we're too loud. We're too much.
所以让我们来谈谈为什么会这样。当我们觉得自己不可爱时，这不仅仅是我们普遍觉得自己不配得到爱，它通常还意味着我们认为我们身上有些东西让我们从根本上成为了一个糟糕的人，或者我们身上有些东西会让别人看一眼就会立刻转身离开。你知道的，这可能是我们性格中的某一部分，是别人告诉过我们“这并不吸引人”或“这并不可取”。你知道的，我们太吵了。我们太多愁善感了。
We're too sensitive. It could be some feature of our body, our weight. our height, our mental health, believing that no one could love us, at our lowest or our past. Each of us has some insecurity, some secret, something that we think almost brands us with this big sign that says this one is unlovable. That's really what it feels like. And the saddest part about recognizing that is subsequently recognizing that somebody else had to teach that to us. No one enters this world, inherently hating who they are. Someone out there, you know, if we think about this hypothetical, there is somebody out there who has never been exposed to, you know, unkind words, who has never
我们太敏感了。这可能是我们身体的某个特征，我们的体重。我们的身高，我们的心理健康，坚信没有人在我们处于低谷时会爱我们，或者没有人能接受我们的过去。我们每个人都有一些不安全感、一些秘密、一些我们认为几乎给我们打上了巨大烙印的东西，上面写着“这个人是不可爱的”。这真的是那种感觉。而意识到这一点的最可悲的部分，随后就是意识到别人不得不把这一点教给我们。没有人来到这个世界上，就天生讨厌自己。总会有人，你知道的，如果我们想想这个假设，总会有人从来没有接触过，你知道的，不友善的话语，从来没有
been exposed to social judgments or media portrayals or unkind statements or bullying or teasing, and they would not have the insecurities that we have because they inherently have a social origin. it's the same thing as like someone who has never seen a mirror could never call themselves ugly. Someone who has never been scolded or shamed or embarrassed or teased about some aspect of themselves will never learn to hate what makes them them and they will always feel deserving of love. So, you know, we learn how to love ourselves by how others have or haven't loved us. That is where this sense of inherent unworthiness typically emerges, it is learned, and therefore it's also taught. So I think the most obvious source of this
接触过社会评判、媒体塑造、不友善的言论、欺凌或嘲笑，他们就不会有我们这样的不安全感，因为它们本质上有着社会根源。这就像一个从未见过镜子的人永远不会称自己丑一样。一个从未被责骂、羞辱、尴尬或嘲笑过自己某一方面的人，永远不会学会讨厌让他们成为自己的东西，并且他们会永远觉得自己配得上爱。所以，你知道的，我们通过别人曾如何或未曾如何爱我们，来学会如何爱自己。这就是这种天生不配得感通常涌现的地方，它是后天习得的，因此它也是被教导出来的。所以我想最明显的来源就是，
sense that we are unlovable is our childhood and how our caregivers, typically our parents showed us affection and showed us care. This is where like the whole theory of attachment style emerges from, you know, the premise being that our initial bond with our parents goes on to shape all future bonds. And if they showed us unconditional, unquestionable love, that is what we will seek in the future because that was the example that was set.
我们觉得自己不可爱的感觉来自于我们的童年，来自于我们的照顾者（通常是我们的父母）如何向我们展示关爱和照顾。这就是所谓的依恋风格理论的来源，你知道的，其前提是我们与父母最初的纽带决定了我们未来所有的纽带。如果他们向我们展示了无条件的、毋庸置疑的爱，那将是我们未来会去寻求的东西，因为那是为我们树立的榜样。
That is the norm. But if they were dismissive or emotionally unavailable, if there was some level of abandonment, if they suffered from something that made it difficult for them to parent correctly, like an addiction or an untreated mental health condition, if they experienced trauma themselves,
那是常态。但如果他们是冷漠的或情感上不可及的，如果存在某种程度的遗弃，如果他们遭受了某种让他们难以正确履行父母职责的事情，比如成瘾或未治疗的心理健康状况，如果他们自己经历过创伤，
you know, that's going to be passed down to us through an avoidant or anxious attachment style because the way that we were able to bond with them was in some way disrupted or disturbed. And there have been a lot of recent studies confirming what I think we already knew, which is that yet again, insecurely attached individuals implicitly often believe that they do not deserve love and it all stems back from these childhood and early adolescent as well origins. It becomes this very deeply ingrained part of their belief system. So especially if there is, you know, a history of abuse in your childhood as well, it is difficult to not internalize those experiences as being a reflection of you, that you were a bad kid,
你知道的，这将会通过回避型或焦虑型的依恋风格传递给我们，因为我们与他们建立联系的方式在某种程度上被破坏或干扰了。最近有很多研究证实了我想我们已经知道的事情，那就是，不安全依恋的个体往往下意识地认为自己不配得到爱，这一切都追溯到这些童年甚至幼儿时期的根源。它成为他们信念系统中根深蒂固的一部分。所以特别是如果你的童年中也有虐待的历史，你就很难不将这些经历内化为对你自身的反映，认为你是一个坏孩子，
that you are undeserving, you are inherently unlovable. Because as children, we kind of don't have any other way to rationalize those experiences. You've got to remember here that our brains try really hard to protect the bond that we have with our caregivers by idolizing them, by creating a fantasy, by almost suppressing memories of their wrongdoing because as children, we are really, really dependent on them for everything. So if we truly believed that they were bad people, that they were seriously trying to hurt us, we would have nowhere else to turn to. so it's a survival mechanism to idolize our parents, to keep coming back to them.
认为你不配，你本质上是不可爱的。因为作为孩子，我们某种程度上没有其他方式来合理解释这些经历。你必须记住，我们的大脑非常努力地通过将照顾者偶像化、创造幻想、甚至压抑他们做错事的记忆，来保护我们与照顾者之间的纽带，因为作为孩子，我们在方方面面都真的、真的非常依赖他们。所以如果我们真的相信他们是坏人，他们是在严重地伤害我们，我们就无处可去了。所以将父母偶像化、不断回到他们身边，是一种生存机制。
Our brains, therefore, have to turn to the next logical explanation for what we're experiencing. And the only other person in this equation is us. And so we must be the problem. We are the issue. A lot of times people who have gone through this abuse deduce that they must be so unlovable as to deserve that experience. and as we get older we know that that is untrue because all of our rational thinking skills begin to click in because we see that other people didn't experience what we experienced because we learn what is actually okay but that doesn't change what has already been done
因此，我们的大脑不得不转向对我们所经历的事情的下一个合乎逻辑的解释。这个等式中唯一另一个人就是我们。所以我们一定有问题。我们才是问题所在。很多时候，经历过这种虐待的人会推断自己一定是如此不可爱，以至于罪有应得地经历这一切。随着我们长大，我们知道这是不真实的，因为我们所有的理性思维能力都开始发挥作用了，因为我们看到其他人没有经历过我们所经历的，因为我们懂得了什么才是真正可以接受的，但这并没有改变已经发生的事情，
it doesn't change that we already have this belief system based in our experiences that we have to unlearn so Freud Sigmund Freud was someone who was really interested in what kind of behaviors this experience creates for adults. And he observed this unconscious tendency, especially amongst people who experienced emotional or physical abuse as children called repetition, compulsion. So back when he was studying this in like the 1920s, he noticed that quite a few of his patients were basically recreating traumatic experiences in new ways, in new scenarios or a new environment. They were constantly in this process of reliving and repeating what had happened to them.
这并没有改变我们已经有了基于这些经历的、必须摒弃的信念系统。所以弗洛伊德，西格姆·弗洛伊德，是一个真正对这种经历为成年人创造了什么样行为感兴趣的人。他观察到了一种无意识的倾向，尤其是在童年时期经历过情感或身体虐待的人当中，被称为“重复强迫”。早在20世纪20年代他研究这个的时候，他就注意到他的相当一部分病人基本上在以新的方式、新的场景或新的环境中重现创伤经历。他们不断地经历和重复发生在他们身上的事情。
And it wasn't a mental process. It's that there was some like unconscious, subconscious part of them that would enter, you know, a new relationship and almost always immediately seek out people who were just like their parents or they would live out their trauma through this new experience. So the reason why he kind of believed that this happened was because, firstly, it was a way to ease the initial emotional trauma by almost getting used to that trauma again and again and again. Like when you keep pressing down on a bruise, the pain lessens because we become more tolerable, less sensitive to it.
这并不是一个精神过程，而是他们身上存在着某种无意识的、潜意识的部分，会进入，你知道的，一段新的关系，并且几乎总是立即寻找那些就像他们父母一样的人，或者他们会通过这个新经历来重现他们的创伤。所以他之所以认为这会发生，是因为首先，这是一种通过一次又一次、一次又一次地习惯那种创伤来缓解最初情感创伤的方式。就像你不断按压瘀伤一样，疼痛会减轻，因为我们对它的耐受力增强了，对它的敏感度降低了。
But he also believed that maybe it was because the reason that it was because the reason this repetition compulsion was occurring, was that it allowed people to gain mastery over the experience. So if you experienced a difficult childhood, a difficult attachment, this kind of theory says that you go looking for that in every new person, because this is kind of all that you are familiar with. And it may be why that not only do we feel unworthy of love, but we also become quite cynical about others' ability to give us love, because we have never encountered a situation that proves differently because there is some part of us that I don't like to say is attracted to bad people because I think that puts a lot of the blame on us, but there is somewhat compulsion that
但他同时也认为，也许这是因为，发生这种重复强迫的原因，是它允许人们获得对经历的掌控感。所以如果你经历了一个艰难的童年、一段艰难的依恋关系，这种理论认为你会去每个新的人身上寻找这种感觉，因为这基本上是你唯一熟悉的东西。这可能也就是为什么，我们不仅觉得自己不配得到爱，而且对别人给我们爱的能力也变得相当愤世嫉俗，因为我们从未遇到过证明并非如此的情况，因为我们内心深处的某一部分——我不喜欢说被坏人吸引，因为我认为这把很多责任归咎于我们——但确实存在某种强迫，
draws us back to the comfort of what was familiar even if that was terrible. So childhood experiences are one thing, and don't get me wrong, they are probably the biggest contributor to a sense of feeling unlovable. But there are many people who may look back at their memories and say, no, you know, everything was so perfect for me. I never wanted for anything physical or emotional. I had beautiful loving parents. Why do I still feel unlovable? And that is where our teen and adult experiences really come into it.
把我们拉回熟悉的安全区，即使那个安全区极其糟糕。所以童年的经历是一回事，别误会我的意思，它们可能是导致“觉得自己不可爱”这种感觉的最大因素。但也有许多人回首往事时会说：“不，你知道的，我的记忆一切都完美极了。我在物质或情感上从未短缺过什么。我有慈爱善良的父母。为什么我还是觉得自己不可爱？”这就是我们的青少年时期和成年经历真正发挥作用的地方。
You know, it's not like we're only influenced by our infancy. We continue to learn and observe and shift. change, evolve, be influenced by experiences and, you know, events way into adulthood. And often I think that our teenage years are just, if not more formative for our sense of self-worth than our childhood. It's really during this developmental stage, this chapter, that we begin to also get a taste for romantic love, beyond the familial and platonic love that we've been used to. It's like, you know, all you turn 13, all your friends turn 13, and suddenly you want boyfriends and you want girlfriends and we begin to perceive that our value is
你知道的，我们并不仅仅受婴儿期的影响。我们继续学习、观察、转变、改变、演变，并一直受到成年后经历和事件的影响。而且通常我认为，我们的青少年时期对我们的自尊心建设来说，即使不是更具塑造性，也绝不亚于我们的童年。正是在这个发展阶段，在这个篇章中，我们开始对浪漫爱情有了初次体验，超越了我们已经习惯的家庭之爱和柏拉图式的爱。这就像是，你知道的，所有人都13岁了，你所有的朋友都13岁了，突然之间你想要男朋友，你想要女朋友，我们开始意识到我们的价值，
in some way derived from whether other people find us attractive or have a crush on us or want to date us or want to hold hands with us want to take us to prom or want to take us to formal and you know as adults you might roll your eyes at those moments and think of them as really childish and really silly, but they're actually really valuable as a way, you know, they're actually really valuable in creating our romantic social scripts. So understanding how people relate to each other. Understand, it's like love with training wheels on. You know, that's what teenage romance, especially in early teenagehood, is kind of like. And if you skip that step, if you've never had it eventually you start to wonder why the further along you get our teenage years are this chapter of
在某种程度上，源于其他人是否觉得我们有吸引力、是否对我们有好感、是否想和我们约会、是否想和我们手牵手、是否想带我们去毕业舞会或正式舞会。你知道的，作为成年人，你可能会对那些时刻翻白眼，认为它们非常幼稚、非常愚蠢，但它们实际上非常有价值，你知道的，它们在构建我们的浪漫社会剧本方面实际上非常有价值。所以理解人们如何建立联系。理解，这就像带辅助轮的学步自行车一样。你知道的，青少年时期的浪漫，尤其是青春期早期的浪漫，有点像那样。如果你跳过了这一步，如果你从来没有经历过，最终当你越走越远时，你就会开始纳闷，我们的青少年时期是充满
ultimate insecurity and comparison and wanting to fit in so when you feel behind in a certain way that can definitely carry with you later into life because it's emotionally significant at the time it's also a period in which we are really developing our self-confidence so even small minor things can disturb that process you know i think i've told you this before but back when I was in high school I had like one boyfriend and it was like really near the end but I spent so much time like watching all my friends get like carried away in these like young romances and never really having anybody who was attracted to me or into me or like wanted to be wanted to date me and sometimes I wonder whether you know I would have had better
极致不安全感、攀比和渴望融入集体的篇章，所以当你觉得自己某种程度上落后时，这绝对会伴随你到晚年，因为它在当时具有情感上的重要意义。这也是我们真正培养自信心的时期，所以即使是微小的、轻微的事情也会扰乱这个过程。你知道的，我想我以前告诉过你，但回到我上高中时，我只有一个男朋友，而且是在非常接近尾声的时候。但我花了那么多时间，你知道，看着我所有的朋友都在这些年轻的浪漫中被带走，而从来没有真正拥有过任何一个被我吸引、或者对我有感觉、或者想要我、想要和我约会的人，有时我甚至会想，你知道的，如果我当初没有觉得自己被冷落，
standards for myself if I had not felt like I was bissing out if I didn't feel quite so desperate, if I didn't feel quite so unworthy based on those experiences. Essentially, the reason this may contribute to feeling unlovable is because it actually contributes to an insecurity about our desirability. That's really the thing about being desired. You can't desire yourself. Somebody else needs to be part of the picture to confirm that you are indeed somebody that is wanted and likable and worthy of their attention. And if that never happens for you, it's hard to feel like, you are actually somebody who is deserving of all those things or who is looked at in that way. That can create a lack of confidence and that is, I think, only exacerbated the older we get
如果我没有感到如此绝望，如果我没有根据那些经历觉得自己如此不配，我是不是会为自己树立更好的标准。本质上，这之所以会导致觉得不可爱，是因为它实际上导致了对我们自身吸引力的不安全感。这才是关于“被渴望”的真正所在。你无法渴望你自己。必须有另一个人参与其中，来证实你的确是一个受欢迎的、讨人喜欢的、值得他们关注的人。如果这种事从未发生在你身上，你就很难觉得自己是一个真正配得上所有这些事情、或者会被人那样看待的人。这会造成自信心的缺乏，而且我认为，随着我们年龄的增长，
and the further we get into our 20s and beyond without still having those experiences. You know, everybody around us is having these flings or these love interests or these big romances. It can really feel like the only question left to ask is what is wrong with me? what don't I have? Why have I not had this experience? You know, it's very easy to also overlook the logical explanations as to why not. You just haven't met the right person. It just wasn't your time. You've been busy with other things. Like those are all super logical explanations for why this hasn't happened yet. But social comparison leaves us feeling lacking and therefore drawing the wrong conclusions about our desirability, our worthiness, and therefore our capacity to receive love.
随着我们在20多岁及以后的生活中继续前进，却依然没有这些经历，这种缺乏只会愈演愈烈。你知道的，我们周围的每个人都在经历这些短暂的恋情、或产生好感、或轰轰烈烈的浪漫。这真的让人觉得唯一剩下要问的问题就是：我到底怎么了？我有什么地方不对劲？我为什么没有过这种经历？你知道的，也很容易忽视那些关于为什么会这样的合乎逻辑的解释。你只是还没遇到对的人。只是时机未到。你一直忙于其他事情。这些都是关于为什么这还没发生的超级合理的解释。但社会攀比让我们觉得自己有所欠缺，从而对我们的吸引力、我们的价值、进而对我们接受爱的能力做出了错误的结论。
So let's turn to another area, which is the experience that happens when we, you know, do start dating or do get into relationships and how that can also leave wounds around our, you know, sense of worthiness. Even before we get into a relationship with somebody, I think frequently experiencing rejections can also really damage ourselves. self-esteem, especially when they continuously happen, we do start to reconsider whether the common denominator is us. You know, if this person didn't text us back after a first date. If, you know, we didn't get as many matches on dating apps as our friends, if this guy, you know, dumped us after like a couple weeks of dating, that can really start to chip away at our self-confidence. I also want to add here,
所以让我们转向另一个领域，也就是当我们开始约会或进入恋爱关系时所发生的经历，以及这如何也会在我们的“价值感”周围留下创伤。甚至在我们和某人建立恋爱关系之前，我认为频繁经历拒绝也会真正损害我们的自尊心，尤其是当它们不断发生时，我们确实开始重新考虑共同的分母是不是我们自己。你知道的，如果这个人第一次约会后没有给我们发信息。如果，你知道的，我们在约会软件上获得的配对没有我们的朋友多，如果这个家伙，你知道的，在约会几周后把我们甩了，这真的会开始侵蚀我们的自信心。我还想在这里补充一点，
that can also be for friendships as well. You know, if you've had a few friendship breakups, if you've had a few letdowns, a few rejections when it comes to putting yourself out there in any capacity in trying to make connection, that all comes back to love, right? That all comes back to feeling desired in a social sense. So it's not just like poor experiences when it comes to romantic relationships can really blind us to our sense of worthiness. Plotonic experiences, familiar experiences can also have an impact. And so what that can create in you is that you feel like the only way to ever have that is to lower your standards, especially when the scarcity effect begins to, you know, kick in
这同样也可能发生在友谊中。你知道的，如果你经历了几次友谊的破裂，如果你经历了几次失望，在任何情况下试图建立联系时敞开心扉却遭遇了几次拒绝，这一切都回归到爱，对吧？这一切都回归到在社会意义上被渴望的感觉。所以这不仅仅是恋爱关系中的糟糕经历会让我们对自己的价值感视而不见。柏拉图式的经历、熟悉的经历也会产生影响。因此，这会在你身上造成这样一种感觉：你觉得唯一能拥有那种东西的方法就是降低你的标准，尤其是当匮乏效应开始，你知道的，发挥作用时，
the sense that this thing is so valuable. It is so available to other people and you don't have it, that you're more desperate to find it, the more you value it. The scarcity effect is essentially, feeling that something is more valuable when it is less available to you. So the less available love is to you, the more valuable it is, the more you will do to obtain it, perhaps the lower your standards become, the less you kind of respect others' ability to respect you. Not every experience with love, whether it is our first or most recent, is going to be positive,
那种觉得这东西太珍贵的感觉。它对别人来说那么唾手可得，而你却没有，你越是重视它，你就越是迫切地想要找到它。匮乏效应本质上是：当某样东西对你来说越不易得时，你就会觉得它越有价值。所以爱对你来说越不易得，它的价值就越高，你为了得到它就会付出越多，也许你的标准就会降得越低，你就越不尊重别人尊重你的能力。并非每一次与爱的经历，无论是我们的第一次还是最近的一次，都会是积极的，
is going to be golden. if there is anything that we have learned so far, it's that the people we love the most can actually cause us the most harm. And that goes for our exes, that goes for the people that we fall in love with. A bad partner can leave you feeling pretty worthless, especially if they've been cruel, especially if they've made you feel like you demand too much, especially if they've spoken down to you, ignored you, never fully reciprocated your intimacy, your love, your generosity, your care. After a while, you change your expectations around what it actually means to be loved and what you actually deserve. You know, if this person you trust and obviously care about
都会是完美的。如果说我们到目前为止学到了什么，那就是我们最爱的人实际上会给我们带来最大的伤害。这适用于我们的前任，也适用于我们坠入爱河的人。一个糟糕的伴侣会让你觉得自己毫无价值，特别是如果他们很残酷，特别是如果他们让你觉得自己要求太多，特别是如果他们贬低你、忽视你，从未充分回报你的亲密、你的爱、你的慷慨、你的关怀。过了一段时间，你就会改变你对“被爱真正意味着什么”以及“你真正配得上什么”的期望。你知道的，如果这个你信任且明显在乎的人，
still doesn't see you was worthy of everything that you give them or everything that you want who is going to believe that you are who is going to give you those things this is a component of narcissistic abuse as well and i don't use that term lightly but it is a component of it that i often see when people find themselves in a situation with a partner who belittles them who wears them down who gives and takes that is so often intentional. Because the poor your self-esteem becomes the less deserving you feel, the less likely it is that you will believe that you can find somebody better, and the more likely it is that you will stay. And that gives them control. Your belief that you are unlovable, that benefits their
仍然不认为你配得上你给予他们的一切或你想要的一切，那么谁会相信你是呢？谁会给你这些东西呢？这也是自恋虐待的一个组成部分，我并不轻率地使用这个词，但它确实是其中的一部分，当我看到人们发现自己和一个贬低他们、消耗他们、一味索取又施予的伴侣在一起时，我经常看到这种情况，而这往往是蓄意的。因为你的自尊心变得越差，你就会觉得自己越不配，你就越不可能相信你能找到更好的人，而你就越有可能留下来。这赋予了他们控制权。你坚信自己不可爱，这有利于他们的
ego and it benefits their intentions. Again, it also often creates this cycle of jumping from one terrible relationship to the next. And it all starts with somebody teaching you that you can't find better. So you accept what you think is normal, which is quite frankly horrible, horrible love. I want to be clear, really clear here, crystal clear. None of that is your fault. None of it. How are you meant to know any better if you have never had an example? How are you meant to think that you deserve better if your confidence has been destroyed. It's not just that you feel unworthy of love as a result of these experiences, but also that you perhaps feel shame, shame around what you've tolerated, shame around the fact that this keeps happening, shame around the fact that you haven't
自负，也有利于他们的图谋。同样，这也经常造成一种从一个糟糕的关系跳到下一个糟糕的关系的恶性循环。这一切都始于有人教导你：你找不到更好的了。所以你接受了你认为正常的、但坦白说极其糟糕、极其糟糕的爱。我想在这里说清楚，非常清楚，清清楚楚。这都不是你的错。一点都不是。如果你从未有过榜样，你怎么能知道什么是更好的？如果你的自信心已经被摧毁，你怎么能认为自己配得上更好的？这些经历不仅让你觉得自己不配得到爱，还可能让你感到羞耻，
found the one yet. And I think this all just continues to trigger, you know, a lack of self-esteem, a sense of unworthiness and the repetition of this experience an identical pattern because there is nothing that is breaking the cycle here honestly it has to be one of the worst things that you can put another person through is breaking down our most precious and core belief which is that we are a lovable creature that we are deserving of love it's you know so crazy to me that people can do that to other people because every person is genuinely just a just so special and unique and deserving. It's like a, it is a basic human need and human right to be loved and to receive love.
对你所容忍的一切感到羞耻，对这种事不断发生感到羞耻，对你还没找到真命天子感到羞耻。我认为这一切都在继续引发，你知道的，自尊心的缺乏、不配得感以及这种经历的完全相同的模式的重复，因为这里没有任何东西打破这个循环。老实说，你能对另一个人做的最糟糕的事情之一，就是摧毁我们最珍贵、最核心的信念，即我们是可爱的生物，我们配得上爱。这，你知道的，对我来说太疯狂了，人们居然能对其他人做出这种事，因为每个人真的都是那么特别、独特且值得拥有。这就像是一个，这是一种基本的人类需求和人权，去爱和接受爱。
So depriving somebody of that or telling them that they aren't worthy of it is, it's criminal. It's also, I think, worth noting that people who are simultaneously struggling with mental health concerns or conditions like depression, like PTSD, like borderline personality disorder amongst many others, they're already at an increased risk of feeling unworthy and feeling worthless and that sense of self-doubt. And so those experiences combined with a traumatic upbringing, combined with early experiences of rejection and shame, combined with a terrible experience in a past relationship, are just going to make you so much more susceptible to this false belief system.
所以剥夺某人的这一权力，或者告诉他们他们不配拥有它，这是，这是犯罪。我认为同样值得注意的是，那些同时正在与心理健康问题或诸如抑郁症、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、边缘性人格障碍等疾病作斗争的人，他们本身就面临着更高的风险去感到自己不配、感到自己毫无价值以及产生那种自我怀疑。因此，这些经历再加上创伤性的成长背景、早期的拒绝和羞耻经历、以及过去恋爱关系中的糟糕经历，只会让你更容易受到这种虚假的信念系统所影响。
And I spoke about this in my episode on dating and mental health in our 20s, but it can be hard to see others valuing you when you're struggling to value yourself as well. It can be a really hard mindset to navigate wanting love, but also feeling like you'll be a burden if you accept it into your life. There are so many different factors that contribute to this feeling of what feels like inherent unworthiness. So what do we do about it? How can we relearn self-love beyond the basics of self-care and self-acceptance, but like truly re-learn at the core of ourselves in the, in our very, the fiber of our being, what we are entitled to and how to raise our standards and how to actually
我在关于我们20多岁的约会与心理健康的节目中谈到过这一点，但当你连自己都难以珍视自己时，很难看到别人珍视你。渴望得到爱，但同时又觉得自己如果把它迎进生活就会成为一种负担，这种心态真的很难驾驭。有太多不同的因素导致了这种感觉，感觉就像是天生的不配得感。那么我们该怎么办呢？我们如何才能超越自我照顾和自我悦纳的基础，重新学会自爱，而是真正在我们内心深处、在我们的灵魂纤维中，重新去了解我们有权获得什么、如何提高我们的标准、以及如何真正
attract good, deep, meaningful love into our lives. So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
把美好的、深沉的、有意义的爱吸引到我们的生活中？在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这就是有自动扶梯时还选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中展现出的心理坚韧、体能以及建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，打破主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会导致炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一番艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO percent。可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Now you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的霹雳瘾（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我意义重大，不仅因为霹雳瘾。我随时准备在白天谈论霹雳瘾，但只是为了让你们知道。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
我的意思是，马克，此时此刻，这是我们讨论霹雳瘾的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。现在你要把那句话说完。是的。我觉得没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客节目《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的丰富经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却依然在追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
你觉得活着的时候做一个好人重要吗？还是说你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的iHeart Radio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改过这特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭开一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Ameriopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
经历过同样事情的另外两个男人：吉尔斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，阿米罗帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If there is one thing that I believe passionately, it's that self-love is not always romantic. It is really tough sometimes undoing an entire belief system, even if you didn't create it in the first place. It is hard to be vulnerable and it is hard to be soft after so many years of being strong and hard and resilient, of trying so hard to convince yourself that you don't need love, that you're better off alone, that you don't care. But I saw this amazing TikTok the other day
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“爱之陷阱”播客。如果有一件事我深信不疑，那就是自爱并不总是浪漫的。有时候，要打破一整套信仰体系真的很艰难，即使这个体系一开始并不是你创建的。在经历多年坚强、硬气、坚韧，拼命说服自己你不需要爱、独自一人更好、你根本不在乎之后，要去展现脆弱很难，要去变得温柔也很难。但我前几天看到了一个非常棒的TikTok
from this woman saying, I know that I'm deserving of love because I love myself. And I was once my own worst enemy. I hated myself more than anybody else in the world. And if that person can still learn to love me, I am sure that somebody else can as well. And that is exactly the attitude that we want to be taking. As cliche as it sounds,
来自一位女士，她说：“我知道我值得被爱，因为我爱我自己。”我曾经是自己最大的敌人。我恨自己超过世上的任何人。如果那样一个人依然能够学会爱我，我确信别人也一定可以。这正是我们想要采取的态度。尽管听起来像老生常谈，
feeling worthy of love really does start with you and it also starts with realizing that it's not just about having your basic needs met it's about actually finding love that is enriching and rewarding and generous and being open to receiving that not just believing that you would like it but being open to seeing somebody offering that to you and thinking that is for me And it begins with kind of showing that love to ourselves and setting an example, not just for others, but for us, that this is what we deserve. There is no love that is off limits to us because we have already shown ourselves the highest form of appreciation and compassion, the highest form of intimacy and connection.
感觉自己值得被爱确实始于你自己，这也始于意识到：这不仅仅是满足你的基本需求，而是真正去寻找那种丰富、有益且慷慨的爱，并且敞开胸怀去接受它——不仅仅是相信你会喜欢它，而是敞开胸怀看到有人为你提供这种爱，并认为“这是给我的”。这一切始于向自己展示这种爱，并树立一个榜样，不仅为他人，也为我们自己，证明这正是我们应得的。没有任何爱对我们来说是遥不可及的，因为我们已经向自己展示了最高形式的欣赏与同情，最高形式的亲密与连接。
So if somebody cannot meet that standard that we are showing ourselves, are they really worth it? I know that sounds like big words. How do we actually get there? Firstly, I think it's important to love yourself where you are at, even if it's not where you want to be. It is a lot easier to say, yeah, I'll start dating again, or I'll be worthy of love when I fix this, when I'm better at that, when I have this thing, when I've lost that weight. But that attaches our value and our worthiness to some kind of weird milestone, to success in something. to output, to productivity, to self-improvement, which is not the case. Our love is inherent. We don't need to change for it.
所以，如果有人无法达到我们为自己设定的标准，他们真的值得吗？我知道这听起来像是大道理。我们究竟该如何做到这一点？首先，我认为在你自己所在的地方爱自己很重要，即使那并不是你想要抵达的地方。说出“是的，等我解决这个问题、等我在这方面表现更好、等我有了这个东西、等我减了肥，我就重新开始约会，或者我就值得被爱”要容易得多。但这会将我们的价值和应得感与某种奇怪的里程碑挂钩，与某项成功挂钩，
It also means that, you know, like I just said, we still believe that love is conditional on something else happening first, rather than just the fact that you are an amazing, cool person as you are right now. That obviously doesn't mean that you can't be committed to self-improvement or you can't want to change something about yourself, but it's important to think about whether you're doing it for you or for somebody else. A relationship, love, that is not a reward for working on yourself, period. I understand wanting to be in the right headspace for a relationship if you've just been broken up with or if you do really want to undo some of those negative beliefs. But I want
与产出、与生产力、与自我提升挂钩，但事实并非如此。我们的爱是与生俱来的。我们不需要为它而改变。这也意味着，你知道的，正如我刚才所说，我们仍然相信爱是以其他事情的发生为前提的，而不是仅仅因为你现在就是一个很棒、很酷的人。这显然并不意味着你不能致力于自我提升，或者你不能想要改变自己身上的某些东西，但重要的是去思考，你这么做究竟是为了自己，还是为了别人。一段关系、一份爱，绝不是为了自我提升而得到的奖励，句号。我理解，如果你刚刚经历分手，或者你确实想消除其中一些负面信念，你会想要处于正确的精神状态。但我希望
you to be honest with yourself. Are you waiting because you're not ready for love or because you still don't feel like you deserve it or because you are scared of what you might find or not find and what that might confirm about you? This is where we need to work on the second of our new and improved beliefs. How others treat you and their impression of your desirability or your worthiness is a reflection of them, not you. I like to think about this as if we are a piece of art. Somebody is going to look at you, to look at you the artwork, and you just might not be their type or their taste.
你对自己诚实。你是在等待，是因为你还没有准备好去爱，还是因为你仍然觉得自己不配，或者是害怕你可能会发现或未发现的东西，以及那可能会证实关于你自己的什么？这就是我们需要努力改进我们的第二项新信念的地方。别人如何对待你，以及他们对你是否具有吸引力或价值的印象，是他们自己的反映，而不是你的。我喜欢把这比作我们是一件艺术品。有人会看着你，看着你这件艺术品，而你可能恰好不是他们的类型或他们的品味。
That's okay, they are allowed to have preferences, but somebody else might come along and look at you and be like, you the artwork, and just it will change their life. Nothing has spoken to their soul more. nothing is better in their eyes. The thing to realize is that the art hasn't changed though. When you go to a museum, it's not like they switch out the paintings based on the preferences of the viewers.
没关系，他们有权拥有自己的偏好；但另一个人可能会走过来看着你，看着你这件艺术品，然后这会改变他们的人生。没有什么比这更能触及他们的灵魂。在他们眼中，没有什么比这更好了。需要意识到的是，艺术品本身并没有改变。当你去博物馆时，并不是根据观众的偏好来调换画作。
You, like the art just continues to exist. The thing that changes is people and is how people treat the art and their perception of its beauty and its worthiness. And that is you. You are the art. It doesn't matter. Like the art does not change, the beauty of the art does not change based on who was viewing it. The worthiness of the art does not change.
你，就像艺术品一样，只是继续存在。改变的是人，是人们对待艺术品的方式，以及他们对艺术品的美感和价值的感知。而你就是那件艺术品。这没关系。就像艺术品不会变一样，艺术品的美不会根据谁在观赏它而改变。艺术品的价值也不会变。
It's still in the museum. You know, that doesn't change based on whether someone sees the technique that it took or sees the effort that it took or sees the colors and the texture and, you know, all the beauty behind it that somebody does not. I think when we detach those two things, you know, our worthiness and other people's opinions, those two things are separate, we are better able to pull from the things. We know to be true about us rather than others' impressions of those things. You are still kind, creative, intelligent, attractive, funny, dedicated, inspiring, motivated, a good friend. You are still all number of qualities despite, or because of somebody else's recognition. That does not change. So the second kind of step to this is noticing when you start also to put words in the mouths of people who have
它依然在博物馆里。你知道的，这不会因为有人看到了创作它所需的技巧、付出的努力，或者看到了别人看不到的颜色、质感和所有背后的美而改变。我认为，当我们把这两件事剥离开来——你知道的，我们的价值与别人的看法，这两件事是分开的——我们就更能从我们已知关于自己的真实事物中汲取力量，而不是依靠别人对这些事物的印象。你依然善良、有创造力、聪明、有吸引力、有趣、专注、鼓舞人心、有动力、是个好朋友。尽管有或因为别人的认可，你依然具备各种各样的品质。这并没有改变。因此，这一过程的第二步是，注意到当你开始将话语塞进那些从未
never spoken them. If someone doesn't message you back after a second date or a first date, you might assume that it's because they thought you were boring or too sensitive or too loud or because you want what they're expecting. We typically put words in other people's mouths. And, you know, did they say that? No, they didn't. We are applying our own false beliefs onto a puppet. but we are projecting our assumptions onto somebody, you know, who didn't text you back because they are emotionally lazy, you know, who maybe got busy. Like, it's not that we're finding excuses for them. It's that we're actually just not assuming.
说过那些话的人的嘴里时。如果有人在第二次约会或第一次约会后没有给你回信息，你可能会认为这是因为他们觉得你很无聊、太敏感、声音太大，或者因为你想要他们所期望的东西。我们通常会把话语强加在别人的嘴里。而且，你知道的，他们说过那样的话吗？不，他们没有。我们是将自己错误的信念投射到一个木偶身上。但是我们将自己的假设投射到某个人身上，你知道的，他没有给你回短信，是因为他在情感上很懒惰，你知道的，也许是因为他变忙了。这并不是说我们在为他们找借口。事实上，这只是说明我们没有去盲目假设。
We are just letting them exist and we are letting ourselves exist and we are recognizing that how they feel about us really doesn't say anything about us. I think that applies to a number of scenarios where we tend to implant our past experience. onto a new situation that really isn't the same, or we look for the most available explanation, which for us is that we're unlovable, but just because that's the most available explanation, doesn't mean that it is true. Often, again, this is all deriving from a false belief, not from fact. I think that that can become harder when, you know, as we spoke about before, they do tell us,
我们只是让他们存在，也让我们自己存在，并且我们认识到他们对我们的感觉实际上并没有说明我们自身的任何问题。我认为这适用于许多场景，在这些场景中，我们往往会将过去的经验强加给一个实际上并不相同的全新情况，或者我们会寻找最容易获得的解释，对我们来说，那就是我们不招人喜爱；但仅仅因为那是唾手可得的解释，并不意味着它是真的。通常，这同样源于错误的信念，而不是事实。我认为，当——正如我们之前所说的那样——他们确实告诉我们时，这可能会变得更加困难，
especially when it comes to an ex or a partner who was emotionally close to us and hurt us. It's really hard to not take those things incredibly personally and carry them with us for the rest of our life. But again, an opinion, a judgment, a cruelty is not fact. It will never be. That can be hard to recover from, but the secret lies in concentrating and borrowing down into what you know is true about yourself and your self-worth, the part of you that stays stable, regardless of others. One way I really bolstered my own sense of worthiness in the face of these experiences was by choosing to almost like have a bit of a love affair with myself.
尤其是当谈到前任或曾经与我们在情感上亲密并伤害过我们的伴侣时。要把这些事情不当做针对个人的，并且不把它们带进我们余下的人生，真的很难。但话说回来，一个观点、一个评判、一种残忍，都不是事实。它永远都不会是。要从这些中恢复过来可能很难，但秘诀在于集中精力并深入挖掘那些你所知道的关于你自己和你的自我价值的真实部分，那个无论别人如何看待都保持稳定的部分。面对这些经历时，我用来增强自身价值感的一个方法，就是选择几乎像是和自己谈了一场恋爱。
Now, I've spoken about this before, but if you want to fall back in love with yourself and rediscover how amazing you are and really begin to defeat those debilitating core beliefs, why not date yourself for a while? and I mean date yourself. I'm talking dinners. I'm talking flowers, quality time, compliments, weekend trips away, you really need to romance yourself. This may sound odd, it might sound a little bit silly. But again, set the example that perhaps hasn't been set for you. Set the standard that people need to live up to because if they can't show you the love that you show yourself, which is honestly the bare minimum,
现在，我以前也说过这个，但如果你想重新爱上自己，重新发现自己有多么惊艳，并真正开始击败那些削弱你力量的核心信念，为什么不先和自己约会一段时间呢？我是指认真的约会。我说的是晚餐。我说的是鲜花、高质量的陪伴、赞美、周末短途旅行，你真的需要对自己进行浪漫化。这听起来可能很奇怪，甚至有点傻。但话说回来，为自己树立那个可能从未为你树立过的榜样。树立一个人们必须去达到的标准，因为如果他们无法向你展示你对自己的那种爱——老实说，这只是最低要求——
are you letting them in just because you don't think you can do better? Or are you letting them in because they are actually worthy of everything that you have to offer? Finally, I recommend therapy all the time on this podcast because it is just genuinely so important and it does work, especially for a sense of unworthiness and, you know, especially knowing that that is really, rooted in childhood and past trauma and experiences, it is so valuable to wrap your head around your response to what you have been through and how that has created your belief system and how
你是仅仅因为觉得自己找不到更好的而让他们进入你的生活？还是因为他们真的配得上你所能付出的一切？最后，我在这档播客中一直推荐心理治疗，因为它是如此真诚地重要，而且它确实有效，特别针对不安全感，你知道的，特别是认识到那实际上根植于童年、过去的创伤和经历，围绕着你对所经历事情的反应以及这如何构建了你的信仰体系和你的自我价值来调整心态，这是极其宝贵的。
that has created your sense of self-worth. And you know, I wouldn't talk about it so much unless it worked. And it's worked for me and so many other people that I know, especially in this case, dynamic interpersonal therapy, which really focuses on how dysfunctional beliefs are based on relationships and how that impacts our mood, but also dialectical behavior therapy, talking it through, getting to the root of your emotions and where they came from, where they were born from. One final reminder for you. The last thing that determines your worthiness, particularly for love, is others. They may receive it and appreciate it, but they should never have the power to influence it. Anybody would be lucky to have you. You are absolutely gorgeous and
而且你知道的，如果不是因为它真的管用，我也不会一直谈论它。它对我以及我认识的许多其他人来说都管用，特别是在这种情况下，动力性人际心理治疗（dynamic interpersonal therapy）真正关注功能失调的信念是如何基于人际关系的，以及这如何影响我们的情绪；还有辩证行为疗法（dialectical behavior therapy），通过交谈，找到你情绪的根源以及它们诞生的源头。给你的最后一条提醒。决定你价值的最后一样东西，特别是对于爱的价值，绝不是别人。他们可以接受并欣赏它，但他们绝不应该拥有影响它的权力。任何人拥有你都会感到无比幸运。你绝对是光彩照人且
beautiful or handsome. Like, no one is noticing the things that you dislike about yourself more than you. You show so much care and kindness, I am sure, to your friends and to strangers and to your family. You deserve for the love that you show others to be directed towards yourself and nothing less. So I am sending so much love, and that is a love that you deserve, not a love that you had to earn. I think that you are incredible for being committed to yourself and committed to healing and committed to thriving and finding, you know, a real deep compassion for yourself. So thank you so much for listening. I really hope that you got something out of this. I hope you learned something about yourself, about your circumstances, about your thoughts, and that, you know, if you didn't learn something.
美丽的，或者英俊的。你看不到别人注意到你身上那些你讨厌的缺点，反而是你自己注意到得最多。我确信，你对你的朋友、陌生人以及家人倾注了如此多的关怀与善良。你理应将你给予他人的爱同样倾注在自己身上，绝不能少于这份爱。因此，我送出满满的爱，那是你应得的爱，而不是你必须通过努力才能赢得的爱。我认为，你致力于自我、致力于疗愈、致力于蓬勃发展并对自己找到真正深切同情心的这份执着是极其了不起的。非常感谢你们的收听。我真心希望你们能从中有所收获。我希望你对自己、对你的处境、对你的想法有所了解，即使你没有学到什么，
something at least, this was a bit of a pep talk and it made you feel a little bit better about your life. Make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple podcast so that you never miss a new episode. And if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to give us five stars, wherever you're listening right now. If you have an episode suggestion, a topic suggestion for me and you want to hear about the psychology of this topic or about something to do with our 20s, please feel free to DM me at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you. And as always, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, and we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
至少这也算是一次鼓舞士气的谈话，能让你对生活感觉稍微好一点。请确保在Spotify或苹果播客上关注我们，这样你就不会错过任何新的一集。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时给我们五星好评，无论你现在在哪里收听。如果你有任何节目建议、给我的话题建议，并且想听听这个话题背后的心理学，或者关于我们二十岁左右的一些事情，请随时在“那个心理学播客”（that psychology podcast）私信我。我很期待听到你们的声音。一如既往，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，我们很快再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts,
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中关于心理坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。也就是数字的2%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客，
or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a hear, unpack what went down,
或任何你收听播客的地方。在《回看》（Look Back at it）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。对我而言，84年也很重大。我是山姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite office. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的嘉宾一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. how many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《艰难学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男性背负着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须使用它。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这段怀孕经历似乎是一场骗局。“欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这需要大批的网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。经历过同样事情的另外两个男人：格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我当时震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听“爱之陷阱”播客。这是一档iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。